my name is Dominic alone on the surface
fatigue i am from chinmaya mission i am
participating in this world economic
forum india economic summit i have been
invited to participate in a panel
discussion regarding culture and
economics i find that it's a very good
plan that there in inviting the
spiritual leaders also to such summits
because it is very necessary that we
integrate the material as well as the
spiritual world because materialism
gives us outer prosperity and comfort
but spirituality gives us inner peace
and joy so both this piece and external
prosperity should come together then
only we can have a better harmony if
there is prosperity but there is no
inner peace that can create lot of
agitation and violence in the world so
it is highly important that as we become
more and more prosperous we should also
get connected to our inner spirit in our
soul so we talk about sustainable
development so while developing
sustainably outwardly we should also
sustain our eternal values then only I
can say it is sustainable development so
wonderful meeting you all so may God
bless you